meet cooper a long next plant eating
dinosaur at around 30 meters long and up
to six metres high at the hip
it roamed this earth more than 90
million years ago
was only discovered by chance in 2004
when a teenager stumbled across what he
thought was a rock
in the australian outback in the state
of queensland
his discovery was the start of a journey
to finding australia's largest dinosaur
and one of the biggest to roam this
earth officially named australia titan
kuparansis
it's one of the five largest in the
world and the only one to have not been
found in south america
australia is one of the most difficult
places to find dinosaurs
unlike south america it's mostly flat
and lacks the mountain ranges and
canyons where fossils are exposed when
rock is eroded
paleontologists had to dig deep to
remove the fossil skeleton from a thick
layer of sediment
each bone has to be removed from
the entombing matrix the rock that
actually surrounds the bones and that's
takes a long time and then each bone
needs to compete
needs to be prepared and compared to
other dinosaurs
from around the world and in in
queensland in particular
and so we use digital 3d technology to
scan the bones so that i can
go and compare them in different museums
and different collections
it's very difficult when you have a 200
kilo dinosaur bone like the ones behind
me
that are that he can't simply just put
in a you know
in a car and take them to another museum
digitally capturing gigantic sauropod
bones and fossil sites has led to
unexpected discoveries
such as several of cooper's bones having
been crushed by other massive dinosaurs
stepping on them
and other skeletons being found in the
same area
there was another another side zach only
a kilometer away
so he moved on to that for another three
years and it's the most complete
dinosaur in australia
it's still to be prepped a lot of it but
um
the preservation of that and the the
amount of bone in that one is
is quite extraordinary it's taken 17
years to find an unearthed cooper and
other species of dinosaurs australia is
one of the last frontiers for finding
them
but it's fast proving to be a land of
the giants
al jazeera